i heard you're going to panama tomorrow
for your boyfriend i'm going to wear an
n95 with a mask over it i'm boosted too
i'm going to have special cockles over
my glasses
and uh well you must need a bad dude i'm
going to go on a full hazmat suit
so is the guy all charged up he asked me
to bring a dildo and i said why would
you want me to bring a dildo he goes
because
i gonna stick the dildo up your ass
you're gonna have to go through customs
you really want to be carrying a dildo
dude why don't you go back i have to go
through your bag yeah great
you must really be in love if you're
doing that dude i got all my std tests
yesterday nice he's getting his he's
gonna wear a rubber right absolutely
okay good all right and i'll have the
pills and the tests what you know you
got to you got to limit what you will
take these anti-hiv pills i thought
you're talking about birth control pills
i'm like i think chris thinks he'd get
pregnant
if i wanted to i could make you pregnant
[Music]
oh my god i'm going to give you some
babies
i want to take your questions this guy
in a graveyard what is it i know
wait till you see the lord that i should
create oh my god like a fire hydrant
going off jesus you see what you do oh
my god he'll start like shaking like
like he's getting electrocuted
[Laughter]
[Music]
like i had to wash my bed my my
like kill bill i mean
everywhere
you need a tarp look into my [ __ ]
i want you to stare at it you will see
how much i love you it's working
all the way to my [ __ ] i want to lick
your taint
and you will be with me for eternity
[Music]
when you come to panama with your dildo
i will give you the ultimate [ __ ]
[Music]
sweet [ __ ] of night
what sweet come they make
into the night with you
greece
we will roam the streets of
panama and then
when i pour down your pants
i will put
my fang marks in your [ __ ] shaft
grease we will [ __ ] to the full moon
light
no farting
christopher
my [ __ ] will fly in your face like a bat
[Laughter]
wow you're a brave man i'm rethinking
this
[Music]